[Musique]
bienvenue à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de paris saclay
tv il ya encore quelques mois ce
bâtiment n'existait pas aujourd'hui
centrale supélec accueille des milliers
d'étudiants votre territoire se
transforme se métamorphosent vite très
vite mais vous êtes consulter
aujourd'hui on s'intéresse au projet de
corps bovine cette transformation
elle s'inscrit dans le plan climat air
énergie territorial comment mettre en
place cette transition énergétique
un workshop concours s'est tenu ici même
à centrale supélec sur cette question à
suivre aussi un projet entrepreneurial
solidaire nous avons rencontré la
cofondatrice de l'application tout route
to go une application qui va à ravir vos
papilles mais aussi votre porte-monnaie
et enfin vous avez dû le remarquer c'est
food trucks qui sillonnent le campus
urbain de paris saclay l'opération vient
tout juste d'être lancé
on fait le point dans un instant
c'est à fait votre territoire est en
constante évolution il se métamorphose
au fil des jours au fil des chantiers et
vous êtes conviés à des réunions de
concertation préalable aujourd'hui on
s'intéresse donc au projet de corneville
il doit permettre de faire un trait
d'union entre la vallée et le plateau il
y à des questions des attentes
écoutez les explications d'admis de
cuite elle est architecte jean baptiste
[Musique]
la quartier de corneville c'est un
quartier qui est sur le plateau et qui a
une relation avec laval est assez
difficile sur lequel il ya un domaine de
château qui étaient toujours pris par
thales le but c'est l'objectif c'est de
faire un quartier très résidentiel où il
y aura surtout dans la partie est
mais aussi avec quelques activités
économiques sur l'ouest et ce qui est
important pour nous c'est que ce
quartier face un trait d'union non
seulement est ouest et qui crée un vrai
lien physique avec le quartier des
moulins et celui de l'école dé
polytechnique mais avant tout aussi un
lien me reçut deux c'est-à-dire plateau
et vallées notre objectif c'est décrit
un quartier au sein du plateau de saclay
mais c'est aussi un quartier de la ville
d'arzew
les gens sont préoccupés parce qu'il ya
plus de monde qui va venir il faut
circuler va y avoir un hôpital il va y
avoir des équipements
du coup il faut que ce soit cuite qu'ont
fait pas des charentes à travers leurs
quartiers là où ils habitent et ils sont
aussi préoccupés parce que qu'est-ce que
c'est un vrai lien plateau au valais
puisque c'est assez difficile
je pense que c'est important de les
écouter mais de toute façon là en tête
leurs remarques sont très pertinents moi
j'étais aussi ravi d'entendre qui
souhaitent et qui sont contents qu'on
peut restaurer le domaine de château et
qu'ils veulent un endroit qui rappelle
l'histoire de ce site et je trouve que
c'est une histoire dont je connaissais
pas tout et puis je découvre aussi qu'il
connaît super bien le lieu où ils
habitent et les environnements c'est par
la vie quotidienne qu'on peut comprendre
ils doivent être les visages des
sauveteurs qui retiennent en hantant les
considérations qu'ils ont qu'est ce que
c'est un commerce qu'est ce que c'est un
quartier avec une centralité qu'est ce
que ça veut dire qu'ils veulent que ça
reste humaine que ça reste à petite
échelle voilà et je pense que c'est
important de le savoir mais c'est assez
proche de notre vision ce qu'on a sur ce
quartier qu'on veut instaurer cette
transformation du territoire elle prend
en compte le développement durable la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
et cela ça passe par la transition
énergétique comment la développer la
mettre en place la valoriser un workshop
concours s'est tenu ici même à centrale
supélec pour réfléchir pour imaginer le
paysage énergétique du futur du plateau
de paris saclay on voit tout cela avec
aurélie noro chef de projet
[Musique]
c'est un workshop concours qui est
s'intitule imaginer le visage
énergétique du futur du plateau de
saclay ve dans les locaux de centrale
supélec un workshop qui est clos
disciplinaire et qui rassemble du coup
une diversité de d'étudiants qui
viennent de plus d'une dizaine d'écoles
donc parisienne mais
bien au delà aussi l'idée de ce workshop
concours c'est de mobiliser sur une
question de valorisation de la
transition énergétique les savoir faire
et compétences pour rendre cette
transition énergétique effective et
désirable l'idée c'est de lier des
savoir-faire paysagiste de design
d'architecturé mais aussi d'ingénierie
et puis aussi d'autres d'autres
formations qui peut agronomie
urbanistique sont aussi représentés ces
étudiants n'ont que viennent des
différentes écoles que sont notamment
l'école d'architecturé de versailles
l'école de paysages l'école centrale
supélec qui nous accueille aujourd'hui
et puis les différentes écoles de design
et d'art son crayon parvient donc
l'initiative de ce workshop a été
permise par la rencontre entre heures
des directeurs du land art generator
initiative qui est un concours
d'architecturé bisannuel et la chaire
paysage énergie de l'école de paysage de
versailles dieu la diagonale
paris-saclay donc qui allie art et
science sur le campus universitaire nous
sommes le design center
et puis évidemment centrale supélec
l'idée à l'issue de ce workshop c'est
que les groupes étudiants puissent
produire des représentations de cette
transition énergétique dans un contexte
territorial qui est celui du plateau de
saclay sont des propositions qui doivent
être aussi ambitieuse puisqu'elle l'a
aussi être révélatrice de cette
transition
c'est une réussite de pouvoir faire sans
montrer également
les enseignants et les institutions à
travers ce workshop qui font que puisse
y avoir de nouvelles collaborations puis
secret ait rendu des étudiants sont pour
l'allemand source d'inspiration pour
l'élaboration du pc a hérité du plan
climat air énergie territorial en cours
d'élaboration actuellement avec la
communauté d'agglomération paris saclay
là ce n'est plus un concours mais un
projet porté par des étudiants de
l'université paris saclay sur
l'entrepreneuriat solidaires ils sont
allés à la rencontre de lucie bages
cofondatrice et directrice de too big to
go une application qui va vous régaler à
petits prix et surtout qui évite le
gaspillage alimentaire
[Musique]
bonjour nous sommes les étudiants
l'université paris saclay donc voici
marion simon guillou minya et moi même
fatma dans le cadre de nos études nous
avons décidé de nous intéresser à
l'entrepreneuriat social et solidaire et
d'en expliquer les mécanismes
c'est pourquoi nous avons interviewé lui
seebach la cie offrande de l'application
tourne autour du cou de taureau c'est
une application mobile qui permet à
chacun d'entre nous de s'engager
concrètement contre le gaspillage
alimentaire
donc l'idée c'est de connecter les
commerciaux quartiers qui peuvent avoir
des invendus à la fin de la journée et
les utilisateurs les citoyens du
quartier qui vont du coup pouvoir passer
récupérer les invendus des commerçants à
la fermeture et donc se régaler à tout
petit prix et contribuer concrètement à
la lutte contre le gaspillage
alimentaire
on connaît les définitions
gouvernementale de l'entrepreneur social
et solidaire qui sont en fait des
critères sur l'apport social de
l'innovation
mais quelles sont les particularités
d'une tête certains compétiteurs au bas
d'une part en termes d'objectifs
nous on vise pas le développement
financier de notre entreprise en fait
notre cahier pièce principale c'est le
nombre de repas sauver et c'est vraiment
sur ça qu'on s'appuie au quotidien il
drive au quotidien ce conduit et pour
moi en fait à une vision tout à fait
différente de regarder le nombre de
repas sauver ou le chiffre d'affaires
annuel de l'entreprise juste visé le jeu
fait plus d'argent et plus d'argent j'ai
vu l'argent on voit plus trop le cas
par contre à se dire que voilà que
chaque jour on est des milliers de repas
qui sont sauvées grâce à ce qu'on fait
au quotidien ça ça veut vraiment dire
quelque chose et je pense que ça change
complètement la mentalité dans laquelle
tu viens au boulot et dans laquelle tu
tu donnes à fond pour ce que tu fais
quoi et comment vois tu l'avenir de le
ss et de l'économie collaborative
et
assez assez assez énorme je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui
se développe de plus en plus que des
problématiques à résoudre y en a des
tonnes et donc et que les gens ont
vraiment envie de s'y mettre aujourd'hui
que forcément avec le digital
il ya plein d'idées qui était difficile
à réaliser il ya dix ans et qui
aujourd'hui sont parfaitement faisable
juste parce que tout le monde est
accessible jeu par le fait qu'on a un
smartphone dans notre tâche
je pense que de plus en plus
d'entreprises ont d'une part ajouté cet
aspect social et solidaire alors à leur
façon de travailler et que de plus en
plus d'entreprises vous secret juste là
dessus et ça c'est plutôt assez plutôt
génial à imaginer
je pense qu'on a de la chance de faire
partie de 2,7 ce mouvement et ce nouveau
monde qu'un train de se créer clairement
il ya eu la révolution industrielle et
puis maintenant il ya la révolution
digitale et ça ça permet et dans les
bonnes solutions positives pour la
planète et pour la société de se
développer donc c'est plutôt est très
enthousiaste
pour se nourrir il ya donc des
applications il ya aussi de nouveaux
lieux nous sommes au musée c'est le
nouveau bar cafétéria de centrale
supélec il vient d'être inaugurée il ya
aussi les food trucks où vous les avez
peut-être vu sillonner le campus urbain
de paris saclay l'opération vient tout
juste de commencer
[Musique]
pour pallier au manque de commerces et
de restauration sur le campus urbain on
a décidé de mettre en place une flotte
de foutra que sur l'ensemble du campus
en partenariat avec les communes et la
communauté d'agglomération
pour cela on va lancer un appel à
projets afin de trouver les bons fous
treuil pour s'installer sur les
différents sites
donc on a lancé ça à l'automne et on a
obtenu une quarantaine de réponse sur
lesquels on a choisi 22 foutraque
finalement qui ont été lauréates cet
appel à projet cfoot vient de rejoindre
ceux qui sont déjà présents sur le
campus du côté d' or c est sur le 4è
camille claudel à palaiseau qui était
présente plus plusieurs années ça vient
densifier l'offre de restauration
parmi ces 22 foutraque on a une offre
diversifiée de restauration du couvre
finalement à la fois des prix différents
pour les étudiants pour les salariés
pour les chercheurs mais aussi des
produits différents des catégories
différentes avec à la fois 2d classique
de la pizzeria du burger mais aussi des
produits végétariens des repas
diversifiée on retrouve sur le campus
plusieurs emplacements
ici on est sûr loin des emplacements le
carré des sciences sur le gif sur yvette
un autre emplacement sur or c est deux
emplacements sur palaiseau l'idée étant
d'offrir
l'offre commerciale et de restauration
aux étudiants et aux salariés aux
différents moments de la journée
puisqu'il y aura des fous très présents
le matin aux horaires du petit déjeuner
pour les gens qui souhaitent prendre un
café en descendant du bus par exemple le
midi pour la restauration à dire plus
classique sur la pause déjeuner et le
soir ici principalement à côté des
résidences étudiantes pour satisfaire
les besoins des de cette population
l'opération vient d'être lancée donc les
fous trucks sont opérationnels depuis
février 2018 pour une période de six
mois en phase test et ont vocation à
être prolongée si ça fonctionne et si ça
on compte son public entre deux pauses
déjeuner n'oubliez pas de jeter un coup
d'oeil à votre agenda avec déjà le mipim
à cannes c'est du 13 au 16 mars le mipim
c'est le plus grand marché international
de l'immobilier le pays apparaît saclay
sera bien sûr présent dans la foulée du
16 au 18 mars
ne ratez pas le haka ton qui est
organisée au proto 204 initiez-vous au
prototypage et créez votre objet
connecté avec les innovateurs de paris
saclay l'innovation encore avec la
seconde édition de tesis des ath system
x sera le 21 mars à partir de 13h30 à
nano innov c'est à palaiseau alors je
vous rappelle le principe les doctorants
de liberté système pics et de l'it et vd
com vous invite à découvrir ou à
redécouvrir leurs travaux de thèse
autres dates à ne pas rater le 29 mars
avec en piste pour l'emploi cet
événement emploi unix déroulera au
vélodrome nationale c'est l'occasion de
rencontrer des professionnels et de
découvrir une multitude de métiers
ce sera de 10 heures à 22 heures voilà
ce qui vous attend pour le mois de mars
mois je vous donne rendez vous en avril
pour une nouvelle édition de paris
saclay tv d'ici là restez informé sur
l'actualité de votre territoire
en allant sur le pap est ce point fr en
regardant tv 78 et n'oubliez pas les
réseaux sociaux merci et à très bientôt
[Musique]